tell the audience about your story how
did you come to these patents how did
you come to these ideas and what are
these ideas
well um
all right it's a long story but
the whole idea started from maxwell's
equations the heavy side version of
maxwell's equations as you well know
maxwell's equations is a series about
that
20 equations with 20 unknowns written in
quaternion formulism it's uh
they were extremely hard to deal with
and don't forget they were actually an
ether theory at the time
later einstein did away with the
luminiferous ether even though she
slightly reintroduced it in 1921 in a
paper that no one wants to talk about so
i won't i think it's called side lights
and relativity anyway
to make a very long story short
i noticed
that a simple dimensional analysis of
the heavy side version of maxwell's
equations a heavy side version of them
they're you know the four equations for
unknowns that every physics student
knows to love
what makes this computer in these
devices that we're using now in our
podcast uh
uh feasible
you could call them the laws of
classical electromagnetism
and they talk about practically uh
electric field e and a magnetic uh
induction term b
also known as
the magnetic flux density and uh a
simple relationship between these two
terms e equals c b
comes out of maxwell's equations where c
is the speed of light
um
now
i noticed that
from
from these equations you could actually
get a term for the pointing for the
magnitude of the pointing vector
and
it comes if you write the pointing
vector
if you go if you refer to my papers and
you can give the papers in your in your
podcast and your uh
feed so so people know how to refer to
them they're series of papers not just
the patents but right the papers that go
yeah so just so you know sal one of the
reasons i'm super excited to be speaking
with you not only well there are many
reasons but one of them
i've been spending weeks going through
these papers i have quite a few here
and i'll link all of these papers in the
description
and um thank you i hope we can get to
some of these notes that i have too
great that'd be absolutely great okay
but to make a very long story short i
noticed that it is possible by doing
this to
okay the whole idea is uh it leads to
controlled motion of electrically
charged matter
from solid to plasma states
subjected to
accelerated spin and or accelerated
vibration
via
rapid acceleration transients this gives
rise to high energy electromagnetic
energy fluxes which are commensurate to
high energy densities
hence it is possible in my opinion
to achieve the schwinger limit that is
electromagnetic energy fluxes uh on the
order of 10 to the 33 watts
per meter square which is commensurate
to energy densities on the order of 10
to the 25 joules per meter cube
so in other words you can lead to
something called a quantum
electrodynamic vacuum breakdown
when you achieve yes so sorry as an
aside for the audience if you're not
following what some of these terms are
don't worry because as we continue
throughout the podcast i'm going to be
stopping style at different points to
explain certain terms like even simple
terms like what is a piezoelectric
material i know it's piezo however
people want to pronounce it what is the
superconductor what is the cooper pair
what is the swinger limit and so on and
so on so this will serve because this
we're going to have another conversation
this will serve as a prelude to that
conversation correct sir and this is
what i love about your podcast not only
do you have a tremendous ability to
understand
your guest's work and you really take
your time and and
i've never seen anybody
uh
the the work of carl fristen for example
was amazing how you were i think you're
one of the few
people who understands the free energy
uh
formalism but anyway um
that was tough well other than he that
is uh yeah
okay i chose it because of your
background in theoretical physics and
mathematics because you are a
truly knowledgeable of this matter and
not only that but you go in detail
as to the work
of the guest which is amazing compared
to other podcasts i i you know i i chose
you and also you mentioned whether you
know on on your rose gold heart
interview you mentioned
if there's any possibility of getting in
touch with me so i said you know
why not just you know
yeah cut the middle man and yeah and go
directly to you the whole idea is is
this you have tremendous ability from
the point of view of your background and
theoretical physics and mathematics and
this is why
i am on this podcast because i want to
speak to um what i look at as a member
of the mainstream physics community i
need to engage with that
with that community
so as to at least
have them look at this work
without
being referred to as a navy ufo or uap
patents and so forth
because there's stigma around that
there is great stigma around that sir
still
and unfortunately even though
certain events
for example have even brought to the uh
this you this new uap uh office being uh
founded and so forth i i i will not i
will not
touch on that on you know unless
you go into that particular subject i'll
keep it
relevant to my work
but it is important to realize that this
particular work
could also have other implications